. Hey, this is really it's either funny or
depressing or horrifying.
I guess it depends on your mood at the time,
but it's definitely notable in the last two
days of the Trump impeachment trial.
Number two, we've seen stunning footage of
what took place on January 6th, including
plenty of previously unreleased footage, video
of senators like Chuck Schumer and others
being escorted out by security and just barely
avoiding an angry Trump mob that in some cases
you see a senator escorted out and then the
mob comes by in the hallway just seconds after
a senator was escorted out.
And now it's undeniable, the stunning reality
of what took place.
And we now know that there are some defenses
that simply wouldn't hold.
This wasn't really a big deal.
No members of Congress were really under threat.
Those defenses don't work anymore because
we've seen all of the footage, but we are
now starting to see some, like Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson, shift to a different type
of argument.
And Tucker is shifting to, you know, it's
all so confusing.
It's impossible to know what really happened
on January 6th, but it definitely has to do
with Black Lives Matter what.
I'm not kidding.
Let's look at some video of Tucker Carlson
show discussing the subject matter presented
during the Trump impeachment trial this week.
And he very quickly gets into, oh, we just
we just don't know.
It's impossible to know, but we're definitely
being lied to.
So what does all of this mean exactly?
We're not sure what it means and we're not
going to speculate.
We do know for certain that the known facts
of what happened on January 6th deviate in
very important ways from the story they are
now telling us, including the story they told
us today in the impeachment hearings.
We don't know what it means and we don't speculate.
But what you're being told definitely isn't
true.
But wait, hold on, Tucker.
Wait a second.
If you have no idea what happened.
And it's impossible to know what really happened.
How do you know that the videos and statements
so far aren't true and then you know what's
coming?
Let's take a look.
And in many places, the known facts bear no
resemblance to the story they're telling.
They're just flat out lying.
There's no question about that.
The question is, why would they lie about
this for an answer?
Think back to last spring, beginning of Memorial
Day.
BLM and their sponsors and corporate America
completely changed this country.
They changed this country more in five months
that it had changed in the previous 50 years.
So now it's we don't know what happened.
It's impossible to know.
But not only is Tucker sure that he's been
lied to, he knows that to understand what
happened on January 6th, we have to look at
Black Lives Matter protests from nine months
ago.
What I sometimes jokingly we'll talk about
how one of the reasons why populist rhetoric
can be so dangerous and deceptive and pernicious
is that populist rhetoric on the left and
right sounds very similar and you can fall
into it.
And then suddenly the solutions you get from
these right wing so-called populists are crazy.
Like we have to make sure Black Lives Matter
doesn't steal your house and we've got to
stop brown people from coming into the United
States.
Tucker is actually doing it.
He's not sure what happened on January 6th,
and he wants the people to know the truth.
We can't have elites lying to us about what
took place.
And despite all of the video evidence and
Trump inciting it, he doesn't know whether
we can even really know what happened.
But he's sure that what Black Lives Matter
did eight, nine months ago protesting the
death of George Floyd.
That's part of what happened.
What let's continue how they do that.
They use the sad death of a man called George
Floyd to upend our society.
Months later, we learned that the story they
told us about George Ford's death was an utter
lie.
There was no physical evidence that George
Floyd was murdered by a cop.
The autopsy show that George Floyd almost
certainly died of a drug overdose.
Fentanyl now Tucker mentions, as an aside,
George Floyd died of a drug overdose dose.
That's not what's been determined.
That's a lie.
Tucker Carlson's lying to you.
The truth is that the medical examiner's office
ruled that the manner of George Floyd's death
was homicide.
It was a homicide.
The cause of death, according to the medical
examiner, was what was described as, quote,
cardiopulmonary arrest, complicating law enforcement,
subdural restraint and neck compression.
It did also mention conditions related to
Floyd's death, arteriosclerotic and hypertensive
heart disease.
He was not a healthy guy from a cardiovascular
standpoint, fentanyl intoxication and recent
methamphetamine use.
But Tucker is lying here.
The medical examiner didn't say that what
happened wasn't a homicide or that what happened
wasn't related to what police officers did
to George Floyd.
He's lying to you while telling you that other
people are lying to you and that the January
6th.
Right.
It's just too complicated to understand.
Let's look at a little more.
But by that point, facts didn't matter.
It was too late.
Cities had been destroyed along with the fabric
of this country itself.
Scores of people had been killed.
Democratic partizans used it carefully concocted
myth, a lie to bum rush America into overturning
the old order and handing them much more power.
It worked flawlessly, so why wouldn't they
do it again?
And then more and more lies the George Floyd
Floyd protests were important.
They were significant.
They received media attention.
But what social or cultural order did they
overturn?
Billionaires continued to get richer and richer
during an economic downturn and global pandemic
wealth continued to concentrate at the top.
Corporations are still in total control of
American society and the economy, and we continue
to see regulatory capture.
What order did the protests overturn?
Yeah, I mean, they raised awareness of issues.
They created new activists.
But what world order was upended?
It didn't happen.
And of course, not only is Tucker Carlson
lying, he's lying to make you forget about
the fact that he's saying, oh, that January
6th situation, we can't really know what happened.
It's just too complicated.
It's too difficult to know.
But you're definitely being lied to.
It's incredible and sad that this guy is a
hero to so many people who unquestioningly
believe everything he says.
And it's going to get worse.
We've predicted that right wing media is going
to be off the rails for the next two years
and it's getting worse and worse